HotforWords.
The word "hysterical" originally comes from the Greek word "hysterikos",...
...which means "of the womb or suffering in the womb," from "hystera" which means "womb."
Back in Ancient Greece, Hippocrates thought...
...that if a woman showed wild swings in emotions, uncontrollable laughter, or weeping,...
...it was caused by her womb or uterus getting loose in her body...
...and causing all kinds of problems.
It would float around in the woman's body...
...and sometimes it would get caught in the woman's throat. Crazy.
Because of the womb theory, that was finally discarded. Only women could be considered hysterical.
Until about 2400 years later, when Sigmund Freud decided that men could be hysterical as well.
And then 1969 came about and the word "hysterical" also meant...
...something so funny that you can't control your laughter, like a hysterical person might.
So that's how the word "hysterical" comes from a woman's womb.
There you go, another mystery solved by your trusty HotForWords.
Bye bye my dear students, be good, love you. Mwah.